can I tell you my rickle story because
you're going to enjoy go ahead I'd love
to hear it it was at a a Vanity Fair
Oscars party and he was sitting at a
table you know uh Black Tie but he'
untied his bow tie and he just looked
very tired and I'm like you know what
I'm going to go over and say this is
this is back when I'm on SNL and so I
take a knee uh next to go Mr Rickles um
um my name is Seth Myers I work on SNL
and he's like oh and he puts a hand on
my shoulder and again I thought he was
like out of it I I thought like look at
this old you know he puts hand I just
want to say I'm so I'm so sorry to hear
what happened with Saturday Night Live
I'm so sorry it got canceled and I go uh
oh it didn't it didn't get canceled and
he goes a guy can
dream he was right up to the end he was
that yeah I went to dinner with a very
old Don Rickles too same thing he stands
up and he starts to obliterate everybody
at the table and I never heard anything
so funny it's the best crazy
what a gift what a gift and and through
it all there was that thing of you truly
believed he loved everybody and so if
you believed a person was like
big-hearted and loved everybody it is
you actually can get away with a great
many more
things